let's take you back a little bit this
year is the 20th anniversary of Jerry
Maguire how about you gonna do Jerry
congratulations she's still my angel you
know working on that script and I worked
on it with Cameron we work he'd been
working on it for a couple years and I
got to work on it you know for a year
with him before we started filming so
there's so many moments of sitting down
and hearing his ideas the music that he
had reading through the script together
and I'll never forget meeting Renee when
she came in there was just magic you
just saw this raw talent just there and
the spark after she left Cameron her
life that's that can't believe that's
Dorothy there she is
and the same thing you know with with
Cuba Gooding when he came in the
character is actually written for
someone who's about six four four really
yes and there was some you know people
were concerned about his height so when
you see when in the movie like you could
see certain things that camera there's a
little Easter eggs camera things that's
the truth
can you handle it just a question
between friends you know oh and when
they call you shrimp I'm the one who
defends you we are adding that as you
know for the for the people who said it
he was in it so many I mean Regina King
an incredible cast we every day you know
Kelly Preston who was amazing yeah in
the film also and yeah it was just it
was one of those experiences when you're
making a movie and just things are
coming together and it's what we all
work for we just know it's just it's
just firing on all cylinders it's just
it's such a joy I'm happy to entertain
you
you